so let's talk about the menu okay the
menu what the did you watch the menu for
the first time this year yeah I did oh
nice yeah I think we I think one of you
guys speak about this um I actually
think I started to slowly get into
horror movies this year and I think the
menu sydne is forcing you to Sydney has
forced me to and she's failed many many
times and I think I'm slowly discovering
the um so I I was I had a tough choice
between two horror movies I wanted to
put on here one was the menu the other
one was all my friends hate me which is
what John recommended I actually went
out and watched it okay and that one I
still think about that one like I I
finished that film and I was like I hate
it but then I had the same kind of
reaction the her where I can't stop
thinking about it so I'll talk about the
menu first um I realiz I realized what I
liked about what I like is the feeling
of uncomfortableness in horror films
maybe not so much like gory or bad
things or scary things happening like
Thriller like I wouldn't call it so much
Thriller cuz Thriller I I felt like
horror was a consequence of the general
story and not the intention like in a
weird way I don't know how to that makes
sense like I didn't feel like a horror
film cuz and with horror films I don't
like it when they when you get into the
movie and immediately they're like it's
a horror film we got horror yeah this
this was like this is a film that
divulges into horror um because of and
you know it has horror element to yeah
but I mean it's definitely Horror by the
end but it was still very very I really
enjoyed this film watch this with this
one I I the I think what drew me to it
was that feeling of uncomfortableness of
knowing that something's not what it
seems to be but you can't quite put your
finger on it like that uncanny valley
feeling oh yeah no no okay that totally
is it it's that uncanny valley feeling
of just being in a situation and not
knowing what's wrong but knowing
something isong something is off totally
and the way that they build this [__] up
and then you pay it off being like haha
this was the thing that was going on in
the background all the time I think this
one had the like one of the best payoffs
I have where it was kind of like
satirizing the whole fine
dining it I really really enjoyed it and
also the actor playing the chef just r r
finds what's his rafin or Colin F I
can't remember which one it was which
one is it it's not Colin F ra right ra
am I crazy is it rafin I mean yeah Rin
Rines is [__] amazing in everything
what else is he in he's in so many
things [__] he's in uh Kingsman uh he's
in uh who is he in Kingsman uh he's like
the MI5 like this is what you're going
to be doing uh that explained it this is
what you going to be doing this is your
like uh your job Alin plays as the this
is what you're going to be play he's the
Nazi and Schindler's List like the
god he's uh in the grand pest Hotel he's
the concierge uh the kingsman oh okay
yes I do know this actor then this man
is in so many films that you've probably
watched he's
Voldemort uh oh he's vort vort Voldemort
he's in uh so he's just the bad guy in
uh yeah he's a bad guy in every film
evil Skyfall he's in the he's in James
as well Prince of Egypt he's in Lego
Batman um [__] walls and gmet um
[__] great film um he's in uh [__]
Sunshine um in he dude literally go
through his filmography it is literally
like backto back bangers damn he's he is
such a [__] good actor and when he
was the main guy main guy in this I was
like I know it's going to be whenever
he's in anything on the poster it's
going to be a [__] good time he's
such a [__] good actor um and I
absolutely love watching him and he was
so good in this yeah I think the scene
that like really really I keep thinking
about is I you've seen the menu right
yeah it's the burger scene just see that
the just seeing this childlike Joy of
someone cooking like this fine dining
Chef cooking this burger I'm not going
to spoil why he's cooking a burger but
he's cooking a burger and it's seeing
this tired old Chef finding Joy cooking
the one of the simplest meals you can
find was
so weirdly heartwarming in such a
terrifying story I was like oh this is
such a mix of emotions that I'm feeling
right now that I that I thought this is
just great film making with great acting
it's not got the most it's not it's not
got the most you know weird script the
most convoluted script it's a simple
story but if you just want good horror
without seeing something horrific or
gory happen watch the menu if you want a
British horror film and uh this
is I I want to talk about all my friends
hate me or I think I think that's the
name it's it's the horror film that John
kind of recommended to me and I would
love for you guys to watch it as well
because I still think about that to this
day it's kind of similar to this where
it has this feeling of
uncomfortableness um something that's
going on in the background the
difference between that film and the
menu is that there is not this kind of
like Big R
the ending is left to like your own the
the ending is left more ambiguous like
aito story yeah yeah yeah um and that
really [__] bothered me when I
finished the film I'm down to watch but
uh the more that time has gone on the
less I can like the more I [__] think
about that film um because that film I
don't like that is the film I think has
given me the most anxiety this year oh
okay and nothing horrific bad happens in
it I call it a British horror film
because it is it is very very much based
around British
uncomfortableness uh and uh what's the
word awkwardness the British UNC
awkwardness and backhanded right okay
that sounds fun I'm down so so so okay I
I'll I'll tell you the opening scene
right so the opening scene is there's
this guy who is meeting him his mates
from uni they haven't met in [__] 10
years or whatever and it it's his
birthday and all of all of his mates
have um have kind of sorted out a big
[__] birthday party for him and he
shows up he's ready to [__] party
it's the middle of the countryside and
it's going to be a massive house party
he shows up he gets the beers out gets
the music out he's like hey guys turns
out the building's completely empty the
building's just complet he's by himself
okay and he's like oh [__] maybe maybe
everyone's just late maybe they got the
wrong time so he cracks open a beer by
himself starts spinning on music Waits 1
hour passes two hour
passes the entire day pass and he's just
by himself oh [__] and they show up at
9900 p.m. or something and everyone's
like I can't remember the name I'm just
going to John what the [__] are you
doing here well we we we gave you a
message that we're going to go to the
pub didn't didn't receive any message
and so this party goes on and weird
Vibes it's just weird Vibes something's
going on there's some jokes that are
made towards him that are just like are
you joking or was that a joke or was
there some was was there some bit
towards yeah yeah yeah yeah and then and
then he's just like oh guys it's it's a
weekend long party he decides to go to
bed and um he he just like guys I know
it's my birthday but I'm kind of feeling
tired I'm just I'm just going to call
early cuz we're going to have a [__]
Banger day tomorrow so he goes up and
one of his mates comes up to him and
he's just and she goes yeah John can i t
you for a second oh like I I know it's
like your birthday and everything but
like not going to lie you've been been a
bit [__] today haven't you oh
God
and you know what I mean I me just like
oh oh kill me now and that kind of
atmosphere
continues through throughout the
entirety of this weekend long party
right and you kind of get hints about
what's going on but you never know if
his friends actually have a problem with
him or if it's just like [__] tongue
and cheek and if it's just some some
kind of like sounds good I'm down yeah
I'm investing I I've never made a film
that's made me feel more [__]
uncomfortable in my life okay I'm H I'm
there I'm I don't I'd be interested to
see what Americans think about it
because it is it is this kind of British
and I think Australian uncomfortableness
that Americans just wouldn't understand
cuz with Americans they'd be like I have
a I have a [__] issue with you you
know if they wouldn't make like some
[__] backhanded jokes um highly
highly recommend it but uh yeah sounds
good uh what's this last one in the
middle last one was the YouTuber I
discovered this year which was
completely out of any kind of like
sphere of Interest I had uh it's this
guy called Fort n okay not fortnite Fort
n he's a motorbike YouTuber I seen this
guy okay you might have seen this guy
right maybe um I discovered him when I
was going through that my [__] veser
phe when when I bought my VES I was I
was just looking for you know videos and
I I have I have seen this guy yeah yeah
this is he is just I like his videos he
is just a a YouTuber where he does
videos on a topic I have almost zero
interest in but he's such a talented
content creator and talented well shot
and like I love the bits he always has
like very like Cinema esque bits before
he talks about something it's really
cool yeah the the best way if I have
like a sentence elevator pitch he's just
top gear but for motorbikes and there
one guy and it's one guy but he is I
think he's Canadian I think he's
Canadian yeah um but you may have like
zero zero interest in motorbikes at all
but he presents it in such a way that
it's not only entertaining but it's
informational and thanks to him I I not
only got more into like motorbike
culture but it also I also leared a lot
that I thought I had zero [__]
interest in and also if you just miss
Top Gear and you miss Peak like Jeremy
Clarkson watch for9 uh he
definitely carries the spirit of that
especially not so much with like let's
say the Special Top Gear episodes but
very much with the weekly Top Gear
episodes where they just review cars but
just have a very very very unique and
entertaining way of reviewing cars cool
and yeah that was pretty much my 3x3 of
the Year and that was our 3x3 of the